Tao kế ngờ Runeus ngày 2018,
ở bán cho Oensay đã quy định hoảng công bố để xuất cấm hoảng tòa như khẩu dầu từng á,
chứ bất cảnh khi chung lãng lượng tàn cầu biến động mạnh và nội bộ a ủ tôn tạnh như bất đồng.
Kế hoặc nay bán đầu sự kiến thương đứa xa và dự tháng tư,
nhưng hiện chưa có thời điểm cựu thay.
Đồng tháng này sẽ khí giá ngắng lượng thân cầu,
gió suông độ tại Trung Đông làm giám bạm hình công,
là biệt tại yêu biển hoặc mốt,
kinh bản chuyển quan trọng của dầu và khí thuần cầu,
sát rau vuy triệu mất cao khiến các nước thành về đều đối mặt với áp được lớn về ăn đi nếu lợp.
Bây giờ kinh đau kinh hoặc cấm sông ngày vóa phát xử phản đối từ một số cuo xa,
nhưng không gà rì và xưa và kia bôn phán phụ thuộc phòng nguồn công này,
nhưng không chân cải liên quan đến đường ông Bruce Bà các chính xích năng lượng
tiếp tục làm phức tạm quá trình đứa ra quy định.
S.H. Lệnh về chi hoảng công làm thư độ một đều xa hàng,
là giám phụ thuộc phần năng lượng hà,
sông chú thấy ai u đang phải kinh mằng giữa kinh tế và một điều địa trình trị.